[Applauso]
buonasera
partiamo dal titolo di questo evento le
periferie della conoscenza la milian
l'idea più semplice la periferia della
conoscenza sia l'ignoranza e la
stupidità che era il vero motore della
storia umana dall'epoca cui adamo ed eva
accettavano di mordere una roba allora
un esempio mirabile di questa periferia
della conoscenza il filmato che ho visto
prima di quel tizio piuttosto che là
sotto che che spiegava come si diventa
leader
raramente ho visto un esibizione di
periferia della conoscenza così totale
profonda e pertinente ecco allora
veniamo al tentativo di spiegare le
periferiche bossi io sono frequentatori
periferie viaggio solo nelle periferie
rifiuti centri urbani e ma almeno è
venuto venendo qui a a biella dove sono
finito in un vicolo terrificante da cui
non riuscivo più ad uscire meglio le
periferie con gli stradoni le le piste
di sabbia e gli orizzonti che si aprono
guarda con attenzione il ho sentito
ascoltato con attenzione l'intervento
non mi ha preceduto che va assolutamente
condivisibile perfetto e ce lo faccio
per una piccola confessione io mi sono
occupato di migranti i periferici del
mondo da molti anni ai da sempre ho
cominciato a occuparmi di africa quando
nei giornali non voleva occuparsene
nessuno perché non facevi carriera
bisognava andare negli stati uniti per
far carriera e dove c'è un e occupavo di
ave opposi qui non avevo concorrenza
mettiamola così paolo degli anni ottanta
del secolo che ci siamo lasciati alle
spalle
allora da quando ho cominciato occupava
di immigranti o di siriano di poveracci
bombardati da destra a sinistra dai
fanatici dai dai ricchi dai poveri dai
gli islamisti dagli anti islamisti però
molto tempo è stato che lo strumento che
doveva utilizzare per cercare di
coinvolgere la gente nelle periferie
della conoscenza e ora sostanzialmente
la commozione
quello che mi aveva anche molto bene
devo dire con grande con grande lucidità
dell'intervento che mi ha preceduto
sono arrivato alla conclusione che è una
via totalmente sbagliata fallimentare
fuori luogo
ho sbagliato per anni il modo di narrare
tanto è vero che nel 2019 alla vigilia
delle elezioni europee
mi guardo attorno nel continente dei
conoscenti el occidente che mi accorgo
che i conoscenti voteranno
massicciamente per coloro che quelli che
dalle periferie vengono che io ho
cercato di narrare coinvolgendo la gente
nella commozione ributterebbe in mare
negherebbe come esseri umani allora c'è
qualcosa che non funziona basta con
questa storia della commozione
buttiamola nella spazzatura della storia
perché la gente non si commuove più non
gliene frega niente
allora l'unico modo per trarre questa
gente dalle periferie e portarli alla
luce della sopravvivenza non della
conoscenza che è una cosa molto
complicata della sopravvivenza e usare
un altro percorso che un percorso
totalmente privo di commozione che anzi
nel cuore la commozione un elemento
negativo che distrae disturba e porta
fuori strada che il percorso del diritto
chico la costituzione degli stati uniti
d'america paese che ha ammazzato forse
più gente di quanti te per i carismi
siano mai riusciti a fare nella loro
lunga storia nella costituzione
americana che l'emanazione
dell'illuminismo settecentesco salto la
parte su dio ci ha spiegato che eccetera
eccetera eccetera
situazione americana c'è scritto noi
riteniamo che sia verità assoluta e
indiscutibile che tutti gli uomini sono
eguali e hanno tutti gli stessi diritti
tv della alla vita alla libertà e alla
ricerca della felicità punto questo è il
diritto non è la commozione è il diritto
nella applicazione rigorosa rigorosa
fondamentalista di questo principio che
ha dato origine a tutti i sistemi del
diritto positivo in cui noi in questa
parte del mondo viviamo
la strada da seguire per raggiungere le
periferie del mondo
l'altra strada è la in versione del
punto di vista una volta stava d'aosta
mi pare un convegno di psichiatri
lodevolissime persone che si parlava di
terrorismo le conseguenze che il
terrorismo ha sulle persone e c'erano
due signore che sono sono fuggite a
degli attentati terrificanti una tunisi
e l'altro nell'altro mi pare a nizza
se quel sito del vestì le persone con il
camion raccontavano che avevano voluto
né nomini problemi psicologici eccetera
eccetera eccetera noi un po
provocatoriamente ho proposto al mio
interlocutore psichiatra tipo la fa una
piccola cosa provate a immaginarvi
qualcuno che subisce e ho scelto
volutamente luogo un bombardamento di
droni americani a raqqa capitale dello
stato islamico
per fortuna recentemente defunto a meno
in quelle in quella forma istituzionale
può ad immaginarvi un abitante dio a
cano e già di sturgis ne frega che è la
sua vita quello di stare sotto le moto
uno dei credo che a vantaggio solo stato
e ci sono 850 mila persone nel 2013
quando ci sono stato io
diciamo che poi si è un po ridotta la
popolazione comunque parliamo sempre di
centinaia di migliaia di persone che
erano tutt'altro che tutti già visti
aderenti iscritti che se la numero due
al partito di abu bakar bada la gente
normale poveracci che sono ritrovati
chiusi lì senza poter andare da nessuna
parte
allora gli avevano sulla testa i droni
americani
provate a mettervi dal punto di vista di
uno che vive a vacca nel palazzone e che
alla sera una scia luminosa nel cielo e
il miracolo della tecnologia americana
gli disintegra il palazzo come
definirebbe quel signore
l'evento parola molto di moda oggi a cui
è stato sottoposto terrorismo è stato
vittima del terrorismo
allora forse il nostro simpatico
psichiatra di aosta avrebbe dovuto
andare anche al h e chiedeva quel
signore questi aveva perso il sonno si
mangiava normalmente come prima se i
suoi rapporti interpersonali ogni
identici eccetera eccetera
allora bisogna che ci misi tagliamo da
questa idea che tutto deve essere visto
secondo il nostro punto di vista
altro esempio classico emigrante allora
provate a proporre al razzista autoctono
e cispadano la domanda tu che sei così
d'artagnan lo faresti il viaggio di quel
signore lì che partito dal fiume riccò
cod really o quell'altro che sta nel
campo di dadaab
c'è gente che ci è nata e ci crepa nel
campo di dada perché il nostro amico di
prima di testimoniare che non si può
uscire perché i nostri simpatici alleati
che ignoti odiano i somali che considero
tutti dei briganti o anche peggio e
quindi non li fanno mai uscire di lì uno
che è nato a dadaab all'inizio degli
anni 90 quando il campo è stato aperto
crepe tra trent'anni ad adam e tutto il
suo mondo che cosa sarà da dub cioè
quella meravigliosa pianura senza nulla
di polvere di mosche e di tafani
che avete visto prima allora proviamo a
fare il viaggio da da da barnes gay e
seduttivo e fino qua eroico difensore
della civiltà cristiana dell'occidente
non ce la fai a fare un chilometro
non ce la faresti a fare un chilometro 5
anni di viaggio per farsi respingere da
qualche imbecille a lampedusa non
faresti un chilometro dei sopra ville
resti alla prima notte del tuo viaggio
allora eliminare la commozione
eliminarla considerata qualcosa di
negativo e di pericoloso diritto diritto
diretto questo l'unica cosa su cui la
battaglia è aperta e che non possiamo
perdere la figura classica di quello con
questo chiudo perché non mi voglio
tediare più a lungo di quello che sto
dicendo è un ragazzo che si chiama vari
geni regis vedrete milione di cose sui
geni tutte magnifiche straordinarie e
entusiasmanti nel suo sacrificio della
sua morte della sua la sua breve vita
eccetera eccetera chiedo ma la cosa
fondamentale è un'altra
a mio parere perché dentro c'è la
lezione
la morale come nelle fiabe lì quando ero
bambino allora regioni era un ragazzo
del mondo del diritto cioè nato
cresciuto studiato nel mondo del diritto
a italia l'inghilterra l'occidente uno
che usciva di casa dallo in biblioteca
leggeva quel che gli pareva non
presenterà la messa o non ci andava
insomma viveva in un mondo del diritto
in cui certe cose non sono possibili o
se anche sono possibili sono violazioni
del diritto e quindi vengono quando i
gendarmi sono abbastanza svegli punite
da un tribunale e non si è accorto che
era atterrato dopo un viaggio che non
era un viaggio puramente geografico ma è
un viaggio attraverso la storia in un
luogo del non diritto che il non diritto
i paesi del non diritto sono i due terzi
dell'umanità
forse anche di più due case di romanità
un posto dove un tizio con la giacca
come la mia che c'è nella tasca un
cartoncino mukhabaraat servizi di
sicurezza ministero degli interni può
andare a bussare in casa virtù come ti
chiami mohammed vieni con me lo prende
lo carica su una macchina senza
indicazione lo porta in un posto che non
è una prigione non è un tribunale non è
ma non è niente una cantina lo massacra
di botte
insieme ai suoi complici la uccide e lo
butta in un canale uno scarico delle
fogne e non succede niente questo è il
mondo che sta intorno a noi e di cui
povero regioni non sia l'accordo non sia
accorto che è completamente diverso dal
nostro in cui la gente in cui civile che
vive in questo modo che vive in questo
modo non gli passava mai per la testa di
andare quando gli vengono a provare a
casa il figlio il marito il nono lo zio
la cugina l'amante di andare il giorno
dopo la polizia magistrati ma come sono
venuti dei tizi senza ordini senza senza
documenti hanno portato via una
settimana che non c'è dov'è andato a
finire non lo fa perché inutile perché è
inutile perché sa di vivere nel mondo
del non diritto e l'egitto non è anche
dei più terrificanti le storie dio e
geni accadono decine di miei
maya di volte ogni giorno in molte parti
del mondo
in molte parti del mondo con cui a noi
abbiamo ottimi rapporti con cui
scambiamo ma questo è un discorso
talmente vecchio e banale che non lo
faccio neanche non lo faccio neanche
quello che mi importa sottolinea è che
se non difendiamo in modo assoluto non
relativo assoluto il diritto è un
sistema non si può togliere un mattone
pensando che resti in piedi
crolla tutto con la tutto perché tutto è
strettamente unito la violazione di un
diritto di un singolo del migrante
all'impatto di una pietra nello stagno
si allarga fa crollare tutto il mondo lo
relativizza l'obbligazione giuridica e
assoluta non è relativa quella politica
ho fatto a casey di laurea sulla
distinzione tra obbligazioni giuridiche
obbligazione policano biologica rifiuta
la trasgressione ma se c'è deve essere
immediatamente sanzionata attualmente
colla sistema allora noi siamo il mondo
del diciamo di essere il mondo del
diritto e se non lo difendiamo
affondiamo non ha periferie dalla
conoscenza periferia dell'esistenza che
è molto peggio grazie
[Applauso]